[Música]
hola muchísimas gracias a todos por
estar hoy aquí de verdad a turnos para
mi mirada mi mirada va a ser hoy sobre
innovación sobre el mundo de la
innovación
en concreto mi punto de vista de cuáles
son los factores más importantes que nos
ayudan a innovar que nos ayudan
realmente a hacer las cosas de un modo
mejor innovación es sin duda una de las
palabras de moda no todo el mundo innova
o al menos lo intenta todo el mundo nos
habla de innovación aunque no tengo
claro si todo el mundo se refiere a lo
mismo cuando hablamos de innovación el
concepto de innovación es un concepto
abstracto ayer lo comentábamos a qué nos
referimos cuando hablamos de innovación
si recurrimos a la definición que dan
los expertos en esta materia se
recorremos así un peter oa peter drucker
ellos definían innovación como el hecho
de introducir cambios significativos en
un producto en un proceso o en un ámbito
que permita
seguir un resultado final por tanto la
innovación es cambios pero con una meta
muy clara la de mejorar la de conseguir
un resultado final mejor por ello todo
el mundo tiene clarísimo que la
innovación es un objetivo necesario todo
el mundo tiene claro que hay que innovar
pero no todo el mundo tiene claro el
cómo tengo la suerte de trabajar en
innovación de trabajar en una parte de
la innovación modesta humilde yo no
trabajo con inteligencia artificial y
trabajo con block change trabajo con
personas con equipos dentro de las
organizaciones que buscan ideas y modos
de hacer mejor las cosas que están
haciendo y mi experiencia estos años
trabajando con personas en el ámbito de
la educación me ha hecho ser una firme
convencida de que el factor humano de
que las personas son la clave
fundamental en cualquier innovación
innovación cuando hablo de este tema con
los equipos de trabajo en las
organizaciones en las que participó o
cuando hablo de ello en mis clases en la
universidad siempre es intento empezar
haciendo una pregunta me gusta empezar
haciendo una pregunta muy sencilla la
pregunta es esta que me gustaría
formular a cada uno de vosotros me
gustaría saber si creéis que podéis
cambiar el mundo y os voy a pedir por
favor que aquellas personas que creéis
que sí que podéis cambiar el mundo que
levanten la mano por favor para saber un
poquito en qué proporción estamos bueno
a 35 o 40 por ciento diría no tengo que
deciros que es un entorno mucho más
mucho más innovador de lo normal siempre
hago esta pregunta siempre depende de
quién tengas delante pero generalmente
suele suele salir un porcentaje paret ya
no un 20% de las personas levantan la
mano puedo cambiar el mundo pero el 80%
de las personas suelen decirte
que el mundo no se puede cambiar que es
muy difícil cambiar el mundo y de hecho
es la es el pensamiento general marcel
proust en una de sus novelas escribía
este párrafo estamos demasiado
dispuestos a creer que el presente es el
único estado posible de las cosas
pensamos que tal como son las cosas hoy
en día van a continuar siendo en el
futuro en el futuro próximo o más lejano
que tal como estamos organizados hoy
vamos a estar organizados dentro de unos
años que vamos a trabajar en lo mismo oa
vivir en la misma ciudad entonces llega
la realidad y te demuestra que no que
todo cambia que difícilmente vamos a
hacer lo mismo dentro de unos años
vivimos en un entorno que cambia
constantemente gran cantidad de cambios
de una profundidad enorme y además a una
velocidad cada vez más acelerada vivimos
cambios tecnológicos vivimos cambios
demográficos fijaos en el año 1800 el
planeta tierra tenía mil millones de
habitantes cuando hoy superamos los 7500
ese cambio demográfico significa a una
mayor competencia en todo no no solo
profesional también en cómo utilizamos
los recursos en cómo utilizamos nuestra
responsabilidad todo cambia y a nivel
personal también seguro que cada uno de
vosotros de vosotras habrá vivido algún
cambio en su vida que tiempo atrás no lo
esperaba o nunca habría dicho que le
pasaría yo por ejemplo me sorprendo a
veces
en mi trabajo hace unos años yo pensaba
que siempre trabajaría en lo mismo
finalicé mis estudios de adn shade
empecé trabajando en temas financieros
18 años de carrera profesional en
auditoría en el control de gestión y un
buen día me di cuenta que en lo que
estaba trabajando no era lo mío yo
estaba trabajando en lo que otros
esperaban que yo hiciera que lo que
realmente a mí me gustaba era lo que yo
le llamaba mi hobby yo de vez en cuando
daba clases y tenía una asignatura en la
que colaboraba y ese hobby en realidad
era mi pasión era lo que me gustaba y me
atrevía a cambiar me atrevía a dejar 18
años de carrera profesional muy buena de
la cual estoy muy contenta muy
satisfechas pude colaborar con gente
maravillosa pero para irme a dedicar a
lo que realmente a mí me gustaba para
sorpresa de mucha gente porque ahí pues
familiares y amigos dicen pero qué haces
marta como dejas 18 años de trabajo para
irte algo en lo que empiezas casi
pero bueno siempre tienes a alguien que
te apoya yo recuerdo una amiga mía
susana me dijo algo que se me quedó
grabado aquí que todavía lo recuerdo me
dijo marta no les hagas ni caso al final
hay trabajos que te llenan los bolsillos
pero que no te llenan el alma y es
verdad necesitamos algo más y así con
ese cambio pues ha aparecido en la
universidad trabajando en temas de
emprendimiento nuevos proyectos
innovación y estos dos últimos años he
estado trabajando con grandes compañías
creando equipos de innovación dentro de
las organizaciones como si fueran
pequeñas startups que trabajan dentro de
la organización y es que cualquier
organización necesita innovar necesita
cambios por muy grande que sea una
empresa y muy bien que le vayan las
cosas sabe que dentro de 35 años no va a
estar haciendo lo mismo o se hace lo
mismo no lo hará del mismo modo por
tanto necesitan innovar el tema como os
decía es como no y cómo lo hacemos por
donde llegamos a la innovación
desde un punto de vista académico cuando
nos ponemos en plan metódico sabemos que
existen distintas fuentes de innovación
la primera fuente de innovación la que
nos ven la que nos viene a la mente a
todos probablemente cuando pensamos en
este ámbito es la tecnología y es lógico
en el momento en que aparece una nueva
tecnología en el que se desarrolla una
nueva tecnología aparece innovación las
hay algunos productos algunos servicios
que cambian y así normalmente solemos
pensar en innovación cuando pensamos en
inteligencia artificial impresión en 3d
big data robótica o block change
asociamos no la tecnología con la
innovación y es verdad la tecnología nos
puede llevar a la innovación pero no es
la única vía hay una segunda vía de
innovación que la hemos visto
repetidamente estos últimos años que son
la que es a través de los procesos
innovación a través de los procesos
procesos
años atrás hacíamos de una forma manual
la hemos pasado a automatizar a
digitalizar la famosa digitalización que
han vivido todas las empresas y eso nos
facilita ese proceso lo podemos hacer de
forma rápida y fácil por ejemplo una
transferencia bancaria teníamos que ir a
una oficina a firmar la autorización una
serie de pasos que ahora son mucho más
sencillos desde el ordenador en casa o
con un simple teléfono podemos hacerlo
por tanto la digitalización de procesos
ha sido una segunda gran vía de
innovación hay una tercera vía de
innovación que es la del mundo de las
startups en el mundo del emprendimiento
encontramos a la estrategia innovación
como estrategia proyectos que llegan
para cambiar el sector en el que
aterrizan que quieren que las cosas se
hagan de otra manera y ahí encontramos
bueno un montón de ejemplos no por
ejemplo ervey en vid no el operador que
ha cambiado como gestión a muchísima
gente no el alojamiento cuando visitan
otra ciudad u otro país
la innovación como estrategia es una
tercera vía muy potente también existe
una cuarta la más modesta la más
sencilla pero yo soy una absoluta
convencida de que es fundamental que es
la innovación a través de las personas
el hecho de trabajar con equipos y
escuchar sus ideas al final si lo
pensamos
en una organización quien mejor conoce
la casa el cliente el sector el producto
son las propias personas de la empresa
si les preguntamos a ellas qué haríais
distinto que le puede gustar más al
cliente en que podríamos mejorar y les
escuchamos tienen un montón de ideas por
expresar que realmente conducen a
innovaciones muy importantes
creer en tus propias personas es una
fuente de innovación fundamental una de
las primeras organizaciones que se
atrevió a hacerlo fue google
creo que google es el caso que todo el
mundo conocemos más no permite a sus
personas dedicar un porcentaje de su
tiempo a pensar ideas a pensar ideas
innovadoras de ahí salió por ejemplo
google streetview a alguien se le
ocurrió porque no podemos ver las calles
de todo el mundo desde el ordenador
y cómo lo vamos a hacer pues alguien que
haga fotos en todo el mundo vaya a
disparate no pues finalmente fue un
proyecto que funcionó y como ése os
podría contar un montón en todos los
sectores las personas tienen ideas si
les permitimos trabajar y expresarlas
trabajar en equipos con distintas
miradas con distintos perfiles que
tengan las personas nos van a dar ideas
bueno e increíblemente potentes y de
hecho no es extraño cuando pensamos en
innovación y ponemos ejemplos en las
escuelas de negocios solemos poner
ejemplos como este solemos hablar de
productos como el smartphone cómo se ha
innovado no sé smartphone recordáis los
primeros smartphones que tuvimos en las
manos
la famosa blackberry su formato era la
mitad teclado y la mitad pantalla
teclado bastante incómodo que teníamos
que utilizar una especie de boli para
utilizarlo parecía que los smartphones
iban a ir en ese en esa dirección sin
embargo apareció alguien con una mirada
distinta apareció steve jobs y nos dio
su mirada de los smartphones y para él
era una absurdidad el tema del teclado
su miraba era un smartphone en el que
todo era pantalla y que simplemente con
el dedo lo pudiésemos hacer funcionar
los tecnólogos te cuentan que la
tecnología que utilizó apple para
desarrollar iphone no era sensiblemente
distinta a la que podía tener acceso
cualquiera de sus competidores la
innovación no estaba en la tecnología la
innovación estaba en la mirada en cómo
plantear el producto y otro ejemplo
todavía más sencillo que me gusta mucho
el de los caramelos un producto que
durante un montón de años fue siempre
igual no un objeto pequeñito que lo
puedes [ __ ] con la mano que los niños
tienen la mala costumbre de ensuciarse
con él a alguien se le ocurrió la
innovación de ponerle un palito de
plástico tecnológicamente estaréis de
acuerdo conmigo que no es muy
sofisticado sin embargo el valor añadido
es tremendo un caramelo que valía dos o
tres céntimos pasa a valer 25
eso significa que valor añadido tiene y
que alguien pensó en cómo mejorar ese
caramelo sencillo no
que todos estábamos acostumbrados son
dos pequeñas muestras oro no para ver o
sólo para decir que la innovación no
está en las herramientas en la mayoría
de innovaciones no viene de las
herramientas viene de las personas viene
de la mirada de las personas del modo
como miran el mundo como detectan cómo
mejorar y ayudar a otras personas la
innovación está en mirar lo que todos
miran y ver lo que nadie vio he empezado
con una pregunta y me gustaría terminar
con la misma pregunta con una reflexión
que hizo la fundación ashoka sobre la
misma la pregunta es si crees que puedes
cambiar el mundo
y la reflexión que hicieron ellos es
este vídeo
salimos a la calle en busca de una
respuesta seleccionamos parejas diversas
padres e hijos novios amigos y amigas y
realizamos un experimento hicimos las
entrevistas por separado y grabamos lo
que pasó
[Música]
vamos a hacer una pregunta muy sencilla
tú crees que puedes cambiar el mundo
yo soy
el mundo
y entonces tener poder no se puede
cambiar nada porque se necesitan muchas
cosas para poder cambiar el mundo yo no
tengo los medios yo sola no tú sola no
porque porque es muy difícil tanta gente
diferente y sobre todo el egoísmo que
hay
mi mundo pues para mí es muchísimo
cuéntanos un poco
muchas las personas humanas honestidad
fuerza
energía esfuerzo darme más confianza en
mí misma que me ayuda de una persona y
para mí ha sido lo más importante de mi
vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cambiamos el mundo deberíamos ser más
conscientes de esta capacidad de cambiar
el mundo muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]